on the next Rick and Morty don't drop
the truth tortoise also whatever you do
don't look into a side now you're gonna
know everything Morty good jobs like
this with the true tortoise to my head
come on Morty come with me
this Morty is my archive of all the
experiences you've begged me to remove
from your life I call them
Morty's mine blowers and we'll be doing
this instead of interdimensional cable
Rick and Morty Sunday at 11:30 knew Rick
and Morty everybody let's break this
down so if you couldn't tell there were
a couple Easter eggs just in this promo
alone but I love the fact that he breaks
the fourth wall again just to tell you
that there's no official
interdimensional cable and I know
everybody's still freaking out about
evil Morty
so there's actually like a
behind-the-scenes promo I'll play in a
second and I'll do a follow-up video for
that later this week too so I'm not
expecting this episode to follow up too
much with that you know maybe post
credits scene but in the way that they
tricked you last week with a standalone
Atlantis adventure this might actually
be somewhat standalone with the
exception of the stuff that they look
back on from previous adventures but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video too but really quick everybody
probably picked up that Morty's
mindspace is sort of mapped out like an
MC Escher painting everybody had to
study MC Escher during grade school art
class but the time tortoise is the thing
that it looks like they plug all these
vials into morty stares into its eyes
and that seems to be the mechanism for
him putting them back in his head so
these are all extracted things that he
didn't want to remember because they
were too terrible or because they were
too unpleasant but if you zoom up you
can actually read what some of these
vials say it's actually pretty hilarious
Mike wrote it what the hell is that
there's a vial that reads virginity
there's one that just says something
balls something probably terrible
happened to his balls there's even
another gravity falls Easter egg there's
one that says Stanford here that's blue
the interesting thing too is there's
only one green vial and it's right over
here everything else is either purple
red or blue so I wonder what that green
one is remember back during pickle Rick
when he was in therapy because he was
going to the bath
room under his desk in class there's a
violin here that reads pocket poo maybe
that has something to do with that but
let me know if you could read the labels
on any of these other vials like some of
these are just meant to be really funny
Easter eggs some of them are probably
pretty genuine terrible things but the
creature that's chasing them down while
they're running with the time turtle is
actually Morpheus the dream Lord from
Neil Gaiman's Sandman comics he's
literally the embodiment of all dreams
so he's probably the protector of this
realm or maybe he just rules in this
place but it sounds like what's going to
happen is is they're just going to
re-experience some of these and they'll
be vignettes and that'll be their
version of interdimensional cable but
you'll be viewing it from Morty's
perspective as they experienced it in
some previous adventure that we've never
seen before so you guys can let me know
what you think about that idea they did
say in a previous comic-con clip that
they will be doing something like this
every year but they were referencing
interdimensional cable but then more
recently they did talk about bringing
all the fan favorite characters back and
they said we you know we want to do it
in an organic way like I have that video
where they talk about evil Marty coming
back and not wanting to shackle an
entire season to him and then him just
showing up out of the blue in last
week's episode so I always take the
stuff they say with the grain of salt
but just let me know what you guys think
of this in the comments below and here's
the clip with them behind the scenes on
evil Morty 3:07 is actually airing after
a time when there's absolutely no way to
not view the world politically at the
time that we were writing it it was a
creative exercise in what could make the
citadel worthy of its own episode we've
only ever seen little glimpses of what
the Citadel really is and this is a
chance to like peel back the layers
explore how does it really work the one
thing that maintains across the entire
group is that Rick's are in charge and
Morty's are beneath them the longer that
we thought about it we realized that's
where a lot of interesting drama comes
from the fun of the episode was treating
the Citadel with as much political
complexity as America as South Africa
the heat in the air and the current
climate both politically ideologically
emotionally is actually the biggest
character in the story and that everyone
it's just playing their little Robert
Altman part no one really gets what they
want in this episode they're all given
their own little twist endings that
definitely aren't meant to be happy
sometimes human being have this urge
when times are complicated and I wish
things were more simple
well one character agrees with you in
this story and it's the character that
needs to be the least empowered this
candidate Morty whose true identity is
revealed at the end as the character
we've met before has had a plan the
whole time and very carefully
orchestrated it I mean I'm kind of glad
we set that up because we got rid of the
Galactic Fed so now we have this like
cool new antagonist I mean he's really
perched in a high position now there's a
lot he could do that place will never
have any bearing over our lives ever
again unlike that mermaid pose this is
the Morty who with we're not just one
step ahead of our Rick but one step
ahead of all Rick's the division I see
is between the Rick's and Morty's that
like the Citadel divided and the rest of
us you know everything is saying is the
right thing it's just that he only said
it in order to manipulate an entire
space station of genius scientists to
give him the ultimate power in the
multiverse which is pretty terrifying to
think about what that protect so the
interesting thing about that is that
they don't confirm when he's coming back
when they're gonna follow up with it
would it be such a middle finger for
them to drop that bomb and then not
address it till season four now I don't
think they're gonna do that I think they
will resolve that in some way but I
think they want to leave threads open
and the way they have in previous
seasons in case they want to pick up
with it in season four or if they feel
like they have some other idea that they
want to get in and they just don't have
time to do everything I think at the end
of the day they nailed all the social
commentary that they were trying to
weave into the episode in the evil Morty
was just a big bonus on top of that like
great mythology pay off in an episode
that had a lot of deep meaning in it in
spoke to a lot of the stuff that's
happening in real life but if you don't
care about that kind of stuff like some
people just want the Rick and Morty fun
adventures it was a great episode that
just had those two characters so I know
some people don't like it as much when
they focus on the other characters
because the show really is built around
Rick and Morty so when they're not
really big in an episode it always feels
kind of weird they even have that on the
black board in the episode
every Rick needs a morty it's one of the
earliest korkin seats of the TV show so
I think there were a couple episodes
this season so far that felt like they
got away from that a little bit so it's
nice when they come back to it in such a
big way where you literally have justin
roiland doing like 99% of the voices in
the episode all by himself when you
think about it because he does Rick and
Morty and this episode was mostly Rick's
and Morty's he did the entire thing
almost himself there were a couple other
people but really it was just Justin
going crazy and he does it so well I'll
be interested to see when we get the
commentary for this episode whether or
not he had to get drunk in the booth
just to do all the different crazy stuff
but we can start spinning theories about
why each of these memories is a
different color and what that represents
red might be four things that he's super
afraid of like really dangerous but one
of them is red and his labeled virginity
so I don't know necessarily that he's
afraid of his virginity but I do love
the idea that he doesn't want to
remember what it's like to be a virgin
what'll happen is is I'll post new evil
Morty in a couple days but leave all
your Rick and Morty requests in the
comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Andre 1603 please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details you can
click here for my episode 7 video and
you can click here for more Rick and
Morty thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]